here are all the companies i could find
who are making quantum computers and
their current highest qubit counts
i've arranged them according to the
approach to quantum computing that
they're taking and i explained these
different approaches in my last video
the map of quantum computing so you may
want to watch that as well if you
haven't seen it
the yellow numbers are for universal
quantum computing qubits and the orange
numbers are for a range of different
non-universal quantum computers or
simulators things that are really
interesting but you can't compare them
directly with the universal quantum
computers
for completeness i've also included a
load of non-hardware companies and
software packages as well
now you've probably noticed that there
are a lot of companies where i haven't
filled in the number of qubits yet
that's because i couldn't find that
information we know lots of startups are
actively working on their machines but
they haven't released information on
them yet
also apologize if i've made any mistakes
here or left anyone out as you can see
the field has grown massively over the
last few years and i had to draw the
line somewhere on the research but this
is my best effort
also things are moving very quickly so
this captures the field in january of
2022 but this will likely go out of date
quite quickly but i thought it would be
cool to capture a snapshot right now
now if we're trying to figure out who's
building the best quantum computers we
really can't just look at the cube it
counts on their own because the number
of qubits in a machine is really not a
very good way of comparing different
quantum systems for example a thousand
low quality high noise qubits will
perform less well than say 10 high
quality low noise qubits
and also not all of these qubit counts
meet the full requirements to count as a
fully fledged quantum computer a set of
conditions called divincenzo's criteria
but i'll be honest i found it quite
difficult to figure out who meets the
criteria and who doesn't but it's
something worth knowing about
so i'd say in the future when press
releases and news reports come out don't
be satisfied with just the qubit counts
for us outside the industry we need more
information to be able to tell how
advanced a company's quantum computers
are because there are lots of factors
that play into the performance of a
quantum computer beyond the number of
qubits like error rates or crosstalk
connectivity even the classical software
that links to the quantum computers
but fortunately there is a way we can
compare different systems regardless of
their underlying architecture through a
benchmarking scheme called quantum
volume
quantum volume is a metric designed by
ibm to tell us how effective a given
quantum computer is
and it's really important to have a good
objective metric that can be run on any
machine so that we can sensibly talk
about how good they are in comparison to
each other and also this helps people
set goals for the future that are
actually measurable and quantum volume
is the best metric we have so far
you can run this test on any universal
con computer and even though the
underlying architecture of the qubits
may be different or how they're
connected or the level of noise in the
system is different this test gives you
a single number the quantum volume which
you can then compare between different
devices
quantum volume is defined as the largest
square circuit your quantum computer can
solve now a circuit is essentially a
list of instructions for the computer
basically an algorithm of instructions
for the qubits
here's an example and in this picture we
have the number of qubits involved in
the calculation on the vertical axis and
on the horizontal axis we've got the
number of time steps and these boxes in
the middle of the operation so the
instructions for the qubits that happen
in sequence first these then these then
these than these
in this example because it involves four
qubits and four time steps this is a
four by four square circuit which
corresponds to a quantum volume of 16
and each time you add one more qubit and
one more time step the quantum volume
doubles as shown here
here are the recent high scores for
quantum volume the machine with the
current highest quantum volume is a
trapped ion quantum computer by
continuum a company formed from the
merger of honeywell and cambridge
quantum their machine has 12 qubits and
a current quantum volume of 2048
ibm's 127 cubic superconducting quantum
computer has a current quantum volume of
128.
so you can see how a machine with just
12 cubits is performing better under
this metric than one with 128 cubits
now the thing is to my knowledge no one
else has published their quantum volume
numbers so we aren't yet able to compare
all of the different quantum computers
with each other using quantum volume
and also although quantum volume is a
good metric for now we know we'll need
other metrics in the future we know
we'll need other metrics in the future
because quantum volume doesn't take into
account for example how long it takes to
solve the problem so what the throughput
of the quantum computers are so another
metric proposed by ibm called clops
addresses this issue it's basically
aiming to be the quantum version of
flops in classical computers
also for quantum volume to work you need
to be able to solve the problems on
classical computers first using quantum
simulators which presumably is going to
be impossible in the future as quantum
computers get more advanced
so to answer who is the best quantum
computer right now according to the
published quantum volume is continuum
system model h12
however this may well go out of date
quite quickly which brings us to the
final part of the video what does the
future of quantum computing look like
over the next few years
now it's worth saying that none of the
quantum computers that exist today can
yet do anything useful they can't solve
any real world problem
any better than the computers that we
already have
so here's the overall road map the
problems people need to solve to make a
useful quantum computer this list was
taken from the google quantum technology
blog and i've linked to it below
first they need to implement error
correction combining several physical
qubits together to make a single error
corrected qubit which has lower noise
called a logical qubit they need to
build this because the information
stored in a qubit degrades over time
ruining the calculations and error
correction is the way to fix this
then they need to show that as they add
more and more physical qubits together
the error correction gets better and
better not worse and worse
then they need to show that they can use
this error correction to create a single
logical qubit that can then be kept
coherent forever so they're able to
continually move the noise away and
preserve the quantum state for as long
as they like they'll need an estimated 1
000 physical qubits for a single logical
qubit at the current error rates but
people are thinking that they'll also
need to reduce this physical error rate
which would then mean fewer qubits are
needed in the error correction
and then they need to create two of
these error-corrected logical qubits to
form a quantum transistor which then
will be able to perform two qubit
operations a key element of a universal
quantum computer
and finally they need to figure out how
to tile hundreds or thousands of these
together to make a full-scale
error-corrected quantum computer
currently people are working on tasks
one and two and every single one of
these tasks is a huge engineering
challenge but this is what everyone is
aiming to accomplish
so the burning question is how soon will
we get through this list well
personally because i don't work at any
of these companies i've got no idea
but many of the companies have set out
goals for the next few years so let's
take a look at what they're predicting
ibm which currently has 127
superconducting qubits has a plan to
have a 433 cubit machine in 2022
then over a thousand qubits by 2023
they've also mentioned up to 1 million
plus qubits in 2026 and beyond which is
quite vague but the 1 million qubit
number is significant because that seems
to be roughly how many qubits you need
to be able to run error corrected
quantum algorithms so how many you'd
need for a useful quantum computer
google which currently has 53 super
conducting qubits is also aiming for a
useful error-corrected quant computer by
the end of the decade so again about a
million physical qubits by 2030 with
working error correction
d-wave currently has a quantum annealing
chip with 5700
cubits which isn't a universal quantum
computer it's a quantum annealer so
currently we can't compare that with the
others they have a plan to build over
7000 qubits by 2024 and also they've
said that they're starting to work on a
universal gate model quantum computer
righty currently has 80 superconducting
qubits and says they'll have a thousand
qubits by 2024 and 4 000 by 2026.
psi quantum who builds optical computers
say that they'll have hundreds of
logical qubits that's logical cubits not
physical qubits and billions of gates by
mid-decade so 2025. although i couldn't
find how many qubits they have right now
so this is the most ambitious prediction
so far
cold quanta who work on atoms in optical
tweezers say that they'll have a
thousand qubits by 2024
iron q have a very detailed plan for the
number of qubits they'll build over the
next few years and they're saying that
these are algorithmic qubits rather than
physical qubits so the actual physical
qubit numbers will be higher but these
physical qubits like i've said will be
combined together to make error
corrected
qubits pascal and cuera both have
quantum simulators right now but are
aiming to convert those into quant
computers and get about a thousand
cubits by around 2024 2025
and this thousand qubit number by then
seems to be a bit of a theme on this
table
and silicon quantum computing is aiming
for 10 qubits next year and 100
error-corrected qubits by the end of the
decade
so this is interesting to look at and
i'm going to be following along closely
to see how the industry keeps up with
these predictions and if i find out
anything cool i'll let you know here
obviously this isn't all of the
companies and i'm sure that the other
companies have internal goals and
predictions but these are the ones that
i could find online
and if these predictions hold up it
looks like we'll have useful general
purpose quantum computers in about eight
years
but the thing i'd like to see in the
future when companies release their
latest news on their latest quant
computers is not just to state the cubic
counts but also confirm that they meet
divincenzo's criteria and also publish
the results of the quantum volume or
whatever the latest best metric is
because without these bits of
information us people outside of the
industry really don't have enough
information to critically analyze these
claims
so those would be good
habits for them to get into
but anyway hopefully that puts you in a
better position to know what to look out
for and also gives you a good idea of
the state of the industry right now i
think it's very exciting to see what's
going to happen over the next few years
especially if people keep track with
those predictions
well that's it for me thanks so much for
watching and if you enjoyed this video
hooray
oh yeah like and scrub bollocks